the batman reviews are in is the movie
another dark night or is it more of a
lackluster night out oh you're really
not as smart as i thought you were matt
reeves the batman introduces us to
robert pattinson's version of the dark
knight who thrillist has described as an
eerie take on the caped crusader the
beat proclaims the new movie is the
first batman incarnation to pick up
nolan's mantle where others have failed
before at this point the film has
already scored a certified fresh rating
on rotten tomatoes of course with bold
statements comparing the latest
iteration of gotham's savior to the one
nolan gave us in a trilogy verdicts from
the other end of the spectrum were bound
to appear opinions are after all a lot
like costumed identities in gotham city
everyone's got to have one but just what
could possibly get stuck in the cowl of
critics who didn't see this new movie as
anything special well by the sounds of
things it seems that their issues have
to do with similar traits to the many
many batman films that have come before
in a 1.5 out of 5 star review for the
washington post writer anne hornaday
said the batman is a film that's as
ponderous as it is convoluted and
ultimately devoid of meaningful stakes
she also describes it as quote another
lagubrious laboriously grim slog
masquerading as a fun comic book movie
naturally considering the genre the
movie is being compared to many
superhero movies that came before it and
for some reviewers it's coming up short
blake howard of dark horizons deemed
that the batman strains to live up to
what's come before
in the very first line of the review
howard writes
the batman is a needless collage of not
only better movies but more egregiously
of better batman movies as director
co-writer matt reeves and co-writer
peter craig create an ultimately
inferior and infuriating vision of the
dark knight if this continues it won't
be long before you've nothing left one
element that seems to be getting a lot
of attention for all the wrong reasons
is the film's run time which brushes up
against three hours this might not be an
issue had it not been for the story
which to some felt overstuffed even with
all of that time to let things play out
a review for tilt magazine described
this new take on the bat as a quote
b-minus serial killer thriller one with
a needlessly convoluted plot too many
characters unconvincing twists and a
terrible villain that last point is
particularly surprising considering that
other reviews have singled out paul
dano's riddler as a high point of the
movie the new york post's johnny
olisenski has nothing but bad love for
the bat as well making comparisons to
the nolan era of the caped crusaders big
screen outings he wrote director matt
reeves downer movie embraces the realism
of the dark knight the opposite of tim
burton's purple-hazed funhouse only
without the payoff of excellent writing
and acting while it's always been an aim
for batman to strike fear into the
hearts of criminals and villains this
movie is eliciting impatience from
reviewers as oliksinsky summed up
there's an unshakable feeling here of
what's the point not to mention the
nearly three hour length holy run time
for some reviewers the movie's cast
proved incapable of elevating the
material including in some writers
opinions robert pattins and his batman
the times kevin marr wrote the
performances are as complex as the color
palette i.e not very
pattinson who has delivered so many
thrilling turns recently struggles to
elevate his anti-hero beyond a pouty emo
brat meanwhile moira mcdonald with the
seattle times said that pattinson isn't
given the opportunity to bring much to
the role instead his young eerily pale
and very intense bruce wayne is another
apparent entry in what she describes as
quote the mercifully sparse brotherhood
of superheroes who are too moody to wash
their hair
take it easy sweetheart of course other
reviewers were effusive about the movie
your mileage may vary maybe it's worth
seeing the film for yourself when the
batman arrives in theaters on march 4th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you